tell me about this look first of all
before we get to green book Xenia and
they're amazing they've been really good
to me and are always making beautiful
pieces and you took it to like a vest
bowtie white Tyler
you got to congratulations Steph and I'm
wearing an uncomfortable shoe but that's
fine it's not about me it's about you
this film has touched so many people
this story what it's about but it's kind
of come out not everyone heard about it
before award season who's sort of a
sleeper what do you make of the success
and why it's resonating I think you know
when people actually go and experience
the film for themselves I think they
tend to tell people about it and and
it's obviously so to me that tells me
that it's resonating with people more
importantly after the fact the pose -
before walking into the theater and
honestly we need to get you a broom
because your sweeping award season honey
Maharshi lufs we've been sweeping
sweeping Richard all right he's done all
right but like you know honestly it's
I'm just blown away by I just doing
something that I love and and people
giving you recognition for the manner or
the approach I guess in some ways how
your work is panned out and turned out
but just to be in the conversation with
other people that I'm so inspired by is
really really a beautiful thing what
sets you apart from a lot of other
actors is that you the work you do
changes the world and the way people
perceive the world you choose your
projects and what you do is important
you know it doesn't feel like you're
throwing your talent away it seems
really important do you realize that
your role moderate these roles can
change sort of the way people feel about
different topics I think my choices are
just a natural outgrowth of how I try to
live my life and so I I try to be
conscious of of my of my diet
holistically whether it's the actual
food you put in the back your body your
like what it is that you're watching and
so when I read projects or I find myself
drawn to some
it's really pretty much in alignment
with with just a larger consciousness
that I try to live with and I'm not
always successful you know I'm I've got
projects out there that I wish did a lot
better you know or that I was turned out
better even but but I just I'm grateful
to even have agency or and have a choice
fun for you question train what's the
next question so I've been having Ken
Jong asked a question of Milo
Ventimiglia Milo has a question for you
and then you have to give a question to
a fellow actor okay your question is do
you put this is from Milo Ventimiglia
from this is us do you put bananas in
your cereal yes I do
Milo that's amazing yeah I do often
would you like me to ask an important
question no I love a banana in my cereal
honestly I haven't even I try to fit in
this dress I'm ready to let go for a
Fatburger right now but okay what do you
want to ask the next question a lot of
you anyone you don't have to say to who
it is just a general okay well what was
the after party you almost didn't
survive that is so good I'm stealing
that for all my et work
[Applause]
you